hagamos un ejemplo más utilizando el
proceso de grandes mid entonces digamos
que tengo un espacio vectorial digamos
el espacio vectorial generado por tres
vectores y estos vectores van a vivir
ahora en r 4 ok entonces tenemos el
vector 0 0 1 1
tengo el vector digamos el 0 1 1 0
ok y voy a tener también un vector el 1
1 0 0
ok entonces el espacio vectorial
generado por estos tres vectores de
hecho es un espacio de tres dimensiones
verdad este vamos a va a ser el que
vamos a trabajar y queremos hallar una
base [ __ ] normal de este espacio verdad
entonces comencemos llamándole este v 1
a éste vamos a llamarle b 2 y este vamos
a llamarle b 3 estos si hacemos el
producto punto vamos a ver que no son
ortogonales de hecho bueno quizás es b 1
con b 3 si son ortogonales pero no todos
entre sí además la norma de cada uno de
ellos no es 1 así que hay que encontrar
un hay que sustituir estos vectores por
unos apropiados entonces
ya no hay mucha teoría que explicar
vamos a ir directo al grano así que
vamos a calcular primero la norma de
este vector verdad porque el primer
vector es una línea y simplemente
queremos normalizar lo entonces b1 el
espacio vectorial generado por b 1 es
una línea y necesitamos que el un
elemento que genere a esa línea pero de
norma 1 entonces simplemente calculamos
un norma que es la raíz cuadrada de 0 +
0 + 1 más 1 verdad es la suma de todas
sus coordenadas al cuadrado sacamos raíz
y esto es raíz de 2
entonces el vector que yo necesito vamos
vamos a definirlo de la siguiente forma
y 1 es 1 entre la norma debe 1 que es 1
sobre la raíz de 2 por el vector b 1 que
es el 0 0
ok entonces este primer vector va a ser
el primer vector que voy a tener que
sustituir en este en este espacio
vectorial generado es decir en vez de
considerar b 1 voy a considerar un 1 y
eso es porque ve que es p b que es el
espacio vectorial generado por b1 b2 y
b3 es lo mismo que el espacio vectorial
generado por 1 verdad pues es la misma
línea la que se genera por b 2 y por b 3
ok entonces uno es el primero de los
tres que teníamos que sustituir y ahora
que sigue ahora tenemos que sustituir de
dos por algún otro vector que sea
ortogonal a un 1 verdad entonces
vamos a considerar vamos a tomar en
cuenta un vector de 2 que como ya hemos
visto en los dos vídeos anteriores es
muy fácil de calcular simplemente es b 2
- la proyección sobre el espacio b 1
donde el espacio b 1 es el generado por
un 1 ok de nuestro vector b 2 ok
entonces además sabemos cómo calcular
esta proyección verdad es simplemente b
2.1 uno por uno y eso lo vimos ya hace
varios vídeos de cómo hacer proyecciones
cuando tenemos bases [ __ ] normales
entonces esto simplemente será b2 que de
2 es el 0 1 10 menos menos y aquí es
donde vamos a hacer un poquito más de
cuentas porque va a ser b2 b2 que 0 1 1
punto el vector 11 que es 1 sobre la
raíz de 2 por 0 0 11 verdad aquí estamos
haciendo b 2.1 y todo esto vamos a todo
eso multiplica al vector y 1 que es
quitar esto es 1 sobre la raíz de 2 por
0 0 1 1 muy bien entonces si hacemos
estas operaciones aquí vamos a tener
bueno este mismo vector el 0 1
10 - y aquí este uno sobre raíz de 2 con
este otro se pueden salir ambos se
multiplican y nos queda uno entre raíz
de dos por uno entre raíz de dos es
simplemente un medio que multiplica
vamos a hacer este producto punto cero
por cero es 0 1 por 0 0 1 por 1 1 con
los otros se los llevamos 10 por 1 en 0
así que aquí nada más me queda un 1 ok
1 que multiplica al vector esto quedó
muy grande al vector 0 0 1 1
muy bien entonces esto no es otra cosa
más que este vector que es el 0 1 10 -
un medio de este un medio de 0 es 0 un
medio del 0 es 0 un medio de 1 es un
medio y un medio de 1 es un medio
entonces esta es finalmente la
diferencia que tenemos que calcular
vamos a obtener este vector de dos dedos
es igual
con este color y dos es igual a 0 - 0
aquí en la primera coordenada de 0 1 - 0
es 11 menos un medio es un medio y 0
menos un medio es menos menos un medio
ok este vector ye 2 es el que
necesitamos entonces podemos sustituir a
de 2 por 2 y tenemos que esto es el
espacio vectorial generado por uno de
dos y de tres pero de dos no tiene la
propiedad de tener norma uno verdad
entonces lo que nos hace falta es
normalizar a este vector quien es la
norma de ye 2 la norma de ye 2 es igual
a la suma bueno la raíz cuadrada de la
suma de los cuadrados de sus coordenadas
entonces 0 + 1 al cuadrado que es uno
más un medio al cuadrado que es un
cuarto más menos un medio al cuadrado es
un cuarto ok y esto simplemente es la
raíz cuadrada de 01 bueno un cuarto más
un cuarto es un medio que si le sumamos
uno tenemos tres medios verdad entonces
es la raíz cuadrada de tres medios así
que ahora sí podemos definir nuestro
vector u2 que es el que ya realmente
vamos a considerar
1 sobre la norma de 2 que es uno entre
la raíz de tres medios o lo que es lo
mismo la raíz de dos tercios verdad
simplemente es tomar el recíproco
y multiplicamos por 2
qué es 01 un medio menos un medio ok
entonces este v2 es el que realmente me
funciona para que para ir construyendo
nuestra base [ __ ] normal entonces
estévez espacio vectorial es el generado
es igual al generado por 12 y por b 3 ok
entonces hasta aquí vamos muy bien y
ahora simplemente hay que encontrar el
tercer vector que sea ortogonal a todos
ellos a los dos anteriores a uno y
agudos entonces nuevamente calculamos el
ye 3 que es b 3 - la proyección sobre el
espacio que generan 1 y 2 que podemos
ponerle nombre podemos ponerle que el
espacio vectorial generado por un 1 y 2
el espacio b2 de hecho bueno no voy a
utilizar mucho esto realmente podemos
hacer aquí directamente las cuentas
porque sabemos cómo calcular la
proyección dado que 1 y 2 es una base
[ __ ] normal para este sub espacio b 2
simplemente es calcular el producto
punto y multiplicar por cada uno de
estos vectores así que vamos a hacerlo
tenemos simplemente la primera parte es
de 3.11 esto que multiplica a 11
más de 3.2
que multiplica al vector u2 esto es lo
que realmente hay que calcular así que
vamos a hacerlo esta es la proyección de
tres sobre el sub espacio de dos y vamos
haciéndolo entonces de tres
73 es igual a b3 que en este caso
dijimos que b 3 era el 1100
entonces este es el 1100 - menos de 3
de 31 100 punto vamos a ponerlo con otro
color punto 1 1 pero un 1 dijimos que es
no lo teníamos ya no lo veo
uno claro aquí está es uno entre la raíz
de 20011 entonces esto es uno sobre la
raíz de 2 por 0 0 1 1 ok y esto
multiplica a nuestro vector 11 que es el
0 0 1 1
muy bien y ahora también restamos
restamos verdad aquí este menos se
distribuye en estos dos y luego restamos
hacerlo con otro color el b3
b3 que era el 1
100 punto
122 es la raíz de dos tercios por 0-1 un
medio menos un medio
y este vector que multiplica nuevamente
a agudos entonces esto es la raíz de dos
tercios que multiplica al 01 un medio
menos un medio
ok entonces si nos damos cuenta fíjense
que aquí el producto punto es 0 de hecho
estos ya eran ortogonales verdad de
hecho aquí pueden ver que es 1 por 0 1
por 0 0 por 1 0 por 1 entonces no hay
nada que sumar todo esto nos da 0 ok
entonces esto vamos calculando
nuevamente esto será igual a este vector
que es el 1 100 menos éste ya no cuenta
y solo jugamos con este vector y de
hecho podemos ver que raíz de dos
tercios por raíz de dos tercios estos
dos escalares salen hasta hasta acá a la
izquierda y la raíz cuadrada de dos
tercios por la raíz cuadrada de dos
tercios es la raíz cuadrada de dos
tercios al cuadrado que simplemente se
cancela a la raíz cuadrada y me queda
dos tercios me queda
tercios y ahora hacemos el producto
punto aquí uno por cero es cero uno por
uno
déjenlos anotando uno por uno es 10 por
un medio es 0 0 x menos un medio es 0
entonces aquí todo esto me da uno
realmente no había nada que agregarle y
multiplicamos por el vector 0 1 un medio
menos un medio muy bien
ok entonces quién es esto esto es uno
menos dos tercios de cero simplemente es
una verdad uno menos dos tercios
simplemente será un tercio cero - dos
tercios por un medio dos tercios por un
medio se cancelan los dos y me queda
menos un tercio menos un tercio y
finalmente cero menos dos tercios por
menos un medio es más y el dos se
cancela y me queda un tercio ok entonces
este vector de aquí ya es ortogonal
tanto a uno como a u2 pero todavía no
terminamos necesitamos normalizarla ok y
de hecho podemos podemos considerar un
g2 prima de dos prima
que sea tres veces este vector porque al
final de cuentas sí sí ya es ortogonal
un vector a otra pareja de vectores pues
cualquier múltiplo escalar de esos es
ortogonal verdad si tenemos aquí un
plano y este vector ok ese no es no se
ve muy bien y este vector es ortogonal a
todo el plano pues cualquier múltiplo de
ese vector también es ortogonal a ese
plano verdad entonces ya 2 prima puede
ser tres veces este que es de dos
keith y tres veces ese es 31 menos 11
entonces su norma va a ser la raíz
cuadrada de 3 al cuadrado que es 9 más 1
al cuadrado menos 1 al cuadrado que es 1
y 1 al cuadrado que es 1 entonces esto
será la raíz cuadrada de 12 que 12 es 4
por 3 la raíz de 4 por 3 es la raíz de 4
que es 2 por la raíz de 3 ok entonces
esta es la norma de nuestro de 3 prima
y aquí era 3 aquí es 3 no sé por qué le
puse 2 aquí en estos estrés muy bien
entonces ya podemos definir nuestro
vector o 3 como uno entre la norma que
es uno sobre dos veces la raíz de tres
por el vector
y tres primas que es el 3
no son dos líneas
entonces el vector es 31 - 11 verdad
entonces este vector con estos otros de
aquí que ya habíamos encontrado estos
dos gemelos copio
vamos a
copiarlos
y copiarlos y los ponemos aquí abajo
pegar los estos tres vectores me dan una
base [ __ ] normal ya acabamos tenemos un
conjunto que que tiene estos tres
vectores y estos tres señores de aquí
serán una base [ __ ] normal de nuestro
espacio vectorial b el sub espacio con
el que originalmente empezamos